يتحدث الآن عن
أعلام كاذبة جديدة يقوم بإعدادها
بما في ذلك
تأكيده أننا نحن
الأسلحة البيولوجية والكيميائية الأمريكية
في أوروبا ببساطة غير صحيح
[موسيقى]
وهم يقترحون أيضًا أن أوكرانيا لديها
أسلحة بيولوجية وكيميائية في
أوكرانيا
وهذا دليل واضح على أنه  التفكير في
استخدام كل من
[الموسيقى]
التي حذرناها سابقًا من
احتمال قيام روسيا بهجمات إلكترونية
ضد الولايات المتحدة ،
بما في ذلك
كرد فعل على التكاليف الاقتصادية غير المسبوقة
التي تكبدتها الولايات المتحدة وحلفاؤها
وشركاؤها
ردًا على الغزو الروسي الإضافي
لأوكرانيا
اليوم  نحن نكرر هذه
التحذيرات ونقوم بذلك بناءً على
معلومات استخباراتية عن التهديدات المتطورة ، حيث تستكشف الحكومة الروسية
خيارات
لهجمات إلكترونية محتملة على
البنية التحتية الحيوية في الولايات المتحدة
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أنه عامل